my goodness Alpha geometry an amazing
Google Deep Mind paper fresh out of the
oven and I think this paper might be
history in the making so how is an AI
that learned on a 100 million
mathematical problems able to compete in
the international mathematical Olympiad
that is perhaps the most prestigious
math competition in the world so did
they achieve a breakthrough well let's
see together dear fellow Scholars this
is 2minute papers with Dr Caro now
competing on such problems is trouble
this requires not just a huge glorified
calculator for adding numbers but it
requires planning your solution logic
and reasoning and more but of course gp4
can do all of that so just give the
problems to it and off you go end of the
video video right well just as a
demonstration gp4 can e the bar exam
would be hired to Amazon for its coding
skills and is better than almost all of
humans on the biological Olympiad so it
can sweep all of these easy right well
let's see if you try to use gp4 and give
it 30 of these tasks it can solve
exactly wow it can solve zero of them I
hope this gives you a feel of how
difficult these problems are devilishly
difficult and scientists a deep mind
just proposed A system that is about a
100 times smaller I can't believe it but
to start how do you even solve such a
problem let's see an easy example for
instance if we ask a human mathematician
to prove that there is an infinite
number of primes we could prove it by
listing them but no one can list an
infinite amount of numbers that is
impossible no so what do we do instead
how do we do the impossible well instead
we start with the assumption that there
is a finite number of primes and then
find a contradiction that says this
assumption cannot possibly be true this
part of the proof requires thinking out
of the box it requires a moment of Brea
ions and without it the problem is
intractable this is akin to pulling a
rabbit out of your head and when you
have the rabbit mechanically finishing
the problem is relatively easy and the
strategy could be that if the rabbit
didn't work try to pick a new one we can
do that but can an AI can a machine pull
a rabbit out of a hat and the initial
answer is no mostly not but let's try
anyway this is how a human would do it
and here is their proposed AI that could
hopefully try to do it so does it work
well let's have a look when given a
problem with blue it first creates the
key ideas the rabbit and then the green
part is the remainder of the calculation
that leads to the solution but this was
easy peasy Now give me some proper
problems oh my now we're talking so
little AI can you solve this and whoa it
pulls the blue rabbit out of the hat and
then runs the green calculations until
it solves it and make no mistake this is
just an excerpt of the solution now hold
on to your papers fellow Scholars
because the full solution looks more
like this my goodness look at that more
than a 100 steps have been concealed
here and it had done all of this
correctly and that is not even the
longest proof it is capable of writing
not even close wow so how good is it
well a previous technique was this good
and the new technique without the rabbit
is this good hm so it is almost as good
as the average mathematical olympi
contestant note that these are really
smart people so the average of those is
also so really smart and it can compete
with that but wait a second this can run
the mechanical calculations but it only
takes you so far you also need the
Brilliance to pull that rabbit out of
the hat and as soon as we add the Rabbit
part of the solution what
happens what are you seeing what I am
seeing it is nearly as good as the
smartest of these super smart people and
fellow colors if you think that is
impressive hold on to your papers
because we are just getting started here
are two mind-blowing facts about the
paper one it learned from scratch by
itself without any human demonstrations
yes the proposed system does all this
without human intervention this is
essentially an AI implementation of the
two modes of human thinking and that is
Thinking Fast and Slow thinking fast is
about quick instinctive responses like
reading something while thinking slow
involves deliberate logical and
calculated decision making this can do
both as well as some of the smartest
humans can do so when we are worried
that this cannot possibly get any better
because there are no humans good enough
to teach it anymore now we know that it
only needs synthetic training data so it
can learn by itself and get this it has
already found more General more elegant
solutions for some of the tasks than
humans did two this project is open
source from day one every piece of the
solution is out there for you for free
yes you fellow Scholars can run your own
experiments with it and all this with a
model that is about a 100 times smaller
than gp4 an absolute slam dunk of a
paper we are still early but I think it
might be fair to say that this is a
breakthrough as incredible as this AI is
note that it is still relatively narrow
it can do geometry but it cannot play
Starcraft or do anything else however
the ideas and Concepts described in the
paper are General enough to make sure
that this can be applied to other
problem domains as well and that fellow
Scholars is going to be a series of
incredible breakthroughs by the way it
is a possibility that I will visit San
Francisco around mid April for the first
time ever if this is the case if you are
a local lab like deep mind and open Ai
and you would like me to visit or if
there is someone who I should really
meet please let me know on Twitter SLX
here you see a set of incredible courses
on generative AI llms all free for
everyone you can learn more about these
things that we talk about here in the
series here from other experts follow
the code they prepared for you and get a
certificate make sure to sign up at wb.
me/ paperc course or click the link in
the description below